so welcome to maps of meaning so the
first question I guess I might have is
what why are you here anybody got an
interesting reason I want to be able to
make manipulate reality to my best
interests that's good plan yeah except
for the manipulate part is it's okay
okay better to work with reality gently
than to manipulate it because it tends
to you know kickback anybody else yeah
oh yeah for the for the better really is
he any good
some friend you are
no wonder he threatens you yeah I bought
into this course
six years ago and this course has
changed the way I see the world so I
want to see after six years what happens
now you want to see if it'll change back
well that's good so why did you decide
why why after all this time did you
decide to come back well I thought about
the things you discussed in the class
over you know over those six years but
now it's been a while and I want to
refresh myself and see you know with the
new experiences I have a new things I've
learned how and what I can take from it
now hmm
that's very uh dedicated and hopefully
useful my friend said get a spiritual
God I hope I didn't see that
he did they did he do any any like just
any description or was it associated
with an epileptic seizure
oh really a oh well that's interesting
yeah that can get out of hand that sort
of thing you know
no that's that's interesting I mean one
of the things that I experienced when I
started to learn some of the things that
I'm going to talk to you guys about is a
very radical increase in the intensity
and clarity of my dreams it wasn't
Pleasant by the way Bob Huff thought it
was useful most useful things aren't
that Pleasant so you're in for some of
the same punishment I guess that's the
plan is it all right all right anybody
else sort of the independent interesting
existential psychology oh yeah etc so
this seemed like a good place to discuss
it
and that took care of your previous
class personnel personality when did you
take that a couple years ago yeah yeah
well it's a good preparation for this
class now do is it like is there anybody
here who doesn't have any idea what this
class is about and just more or less
showed up because the time was right or
anything like that so you don't really
have any idea what you're in for
all right well I'm going to jump right
into it because why not and I'll spend
so I'm going to talk to you for about
two hours and then you can have a break
and then I'm going to tell you what you
have to do in the class okay so but by
that time you'll know if you want to
take the class because you'll know
whether or not you are interested in
what I told you about so I'm going to
video the class I always do that and so
the videos will be online these ones
from previous years are online as well
so you know hopefully that'll be a
useful resource it shouldn't take me as
much set-up time the next time as it did
today you know I'm still getting used to
this equipment so alright so I want to
tell you why I'm telling you the things
that I'm going to tell you I mean when I
was approximately the same age that you
people are probably a little bit older
because I imagine you guys around 21 or
something like that I was probably about
your age and then maybe a couple years
older first year I was in graduate
school in particular which I guess was
in 1985 so I was 23 then um that was it
like I said that was in 1985 and there
were a couple of times in the late 20th
century where the Cold War really came
to a peak and one time I guess was
probably in about 1957 when I think it
was 57 I hope I have my dates right was
whenever Stalin announced that he had
developed a hydrogen bomb now I don't
know how much you guys know about
hydrogen bombs but all you really need
to know about a hydrogen bomb is that
they use atom bombs as a trigger so
they're they're quite the weapon and the
USSR in the u.s. made some very very big
ones they're big enough to make the
thing that was dropped on Hiroshima look
like dynamite you know so hundreds and
hundreds of times bigger maybe thousands
of times it's been a while since I
looked into it and then in 1962 there
was the Cuban Missile Crisis not a good
story about that so about 10 years ago I
went down to
tucson arizona to a conference on
consciousness there and they have that
conference fairly frequently in tucson
it's become quite a popular conference
even though it isn't clear to me that we
know anything more about consciousness
than we did before the conference
started and tucson is kind of an
interesting town it's in the middle of
the desert the cool desert you know with
the big sort of so arrow roadrunner
cactuses and but it's also extremely dry
there which is of course what you'd
expect given that it's a desert so one
of the things the americans do with
tucson is store old fighter planes there
and so there's a airplane museum which
is an amazing place it has maybe five
hundred planes including john f
kennedy's air force one right which is
the jet that he used to zoom around the
world it didn't even have a shower in it
by the way it's funny because on outside
it looks like a modern jet but on the
inside it looks pretty much like it was
from World War two you know because 1962
is a lot closer to World War Two than it
is to now in all sorts of ways even the
Rockets that went to the moon looked
like they were built by people who were
using World War two technology right
there full of switches mechanical
switches and they're it's pretty basic
anyways as well as the airport museum
which is a very interesting place does
b-52 bombers there and all sorts of
things those things are huge there's
also an airport graveyard where they
store old fighter jets and there's a lot
of old fighter jet so there's acres and
acres and acres and acres and thousands
and thousands of old Morpho fighter jets
lined up in the desert so that's kind of
cool in a strange way but there was one
other thing down there that I went and
saw which was a decommissioned nuclear
missile site and it was a
intercontinental ballistic missile site
and those were built in the 50s and
early 60s and they were major league
rockets those things you know I think
the silo because we could go into the
silo the missiles weren't there anymore
we could go into the silo and it was
certainly farther across in diameter
than this room I would think probably
twice as twice as large as this room so
you could imagine how big a missile that
would be it it's
your grandmother's missile it's a
major-league piece of armament and out
on the ground so if these things were
underground right deep underground
because they didn't want them to get
blown up if they were bombed so they
buried them quite a long ways down and
to get into it you had to go through
this massive steel door that was like a
huge safe door except you know 10 times
this big and ten times as thick out in
the yard of the nuclear missile site
there were fences with barbed wire on
them of course and there was a missile
cap you know so be the nosecone of the
missile down some of these missiles had
single warheads and which were more than
sufficient to demolish a city and some
of them had multiple warheads so they
would shoot out into space and then come
back into earth and then they
essentially break apart or disperse into
multiple missiles and then you could
really bomb the hell out of whatever you
were going to bomb instead of you know
just destroying one city and so the
nosecone was sitting out there and that
was a pretty freaky looking thing I'll
tell you it like it was big it was about
seven feet high I would think and maybe
about the same amount of cross and it
was made out of this plastic kind of a
variegated plastic material that was
about 3/4 of an inch thick and then it
would melt off of course on re-entry
because as I said these things shot out
into space and so I was you know kind of
unnerving really in a serious way and
then so we're at the missile site and
you know I mentioned your grandmother's
missile and that there was actually a
reason for that it was a bit of
foreshadowing because it was a very
funny place because at the front of the
missile site there was sort of this
museum set up you know and it had
pictures of Reagan and Gorbachev on it
because they decommissioned the missile
sites you know when day tonto occurred
and then when when perestroika hit and
the Soviet Union started to collapse and
so there was all these pictures of
Reagan and Gorbachev from 1984 and so
the museum was kind of like a time
capsule of 1984 and the people who were
running it were like retired Arizonans
and they were like your grandparents
assuming you have retired Arizonans for
your grandparents but they're real
friendly and you know they're pretty
happy to show you their nuclear missile
museum and it was sort of like being in
their rec room except that it was a
your missile site you know and they were
hospitable and it was weird you know
it's like welcome to you know welcome
people to a nuclear missile site and no
it's just not it's just not reasonable
so it was very disconcerting and it was
disconcerting that it was locked in the
1980s and then it was disconcerting that
it was friendly and hospitable and you
know they were kind of proud to show it
off and happy to be there and then when
you went down into the nuclear missile
silo proper the control center it sort
of looked like Star Trek you know from
1966 or 1967 except more primitive I
don't remember if the Star Trek control
Command area was modeled after the
nuclear missile site control systems or
if it was the other way around but I
suspect it was they were modeled after
the nuclear controls but that was really
1950s like the whole place was painted
in that pastel green you know late 50s
and early 60s people really liked and it
was it had this 1950s um what would he
called aesthetic and you wouldn't
necessarily think that a nuclear missile
site would have an aesthetic but it does
and it looked like high-tech 1957 you
know 1957 technology and so they brought
you into the control room and the
control desk was probably or the module
or whatever you might call it was about
three times as long as this maybe four
times I'm not pretty impressive piece of
machinery and the way you launch the
missiles was not to secure in my humble
opinion what happened was one guy wore
the key around his neck and another guy
wore the key around his neck and then in
order to launch the sights you had to
put the keys in at the same time and
they were far enough apart so nobody
could stretch their arms you know which
was the kind of the you know high-tech
part of it so and you had to put the key
in and then he both had to turn the key
for ten seconds okay so now one of the
things that you may know about ballistic
missiles or you may not is they're not
cruise missiles man once you set those
things off they're not coming back
they're bullets that's what makes them
ballistic so you know if you aim a gun
at someone and you shoot and you decide
halfway when the bullets halfway there
that maybe that wasn't a good thing to
do it's a little late because you're not
tell
that bullet to come back and it's the
same with ballistic missiles and those
things are going a lot faster than
bullets you know like a 22 bullet that
was about the speed of sound six hundred
miles an hour or so but a ballistic
missile that thing has to go seven miles
a second to get out of the gravity near
earth now I'm not sure they go quite
that fast because that's escape velocity
right you need to do that to get out of
the gravitational well but to get out
there into space you have to be damn
close to seven miles a second and so
it's a bullet very large bullet with a
very explosive head on it going seven
miles a second and once you turn those
two keys man it's good that's it there's
no there's no turning back that's that
and so they took us through a simulated
launch which still kind of it's still an
uncanny feeling remembering that you
know because it was it's a hell of a
thing to apprehend and then they told us
that the keys were in once right so we
were ten seconds away now they wouldn't
tell us when but we know when it was
during the Cuban Missile Crisis so you
know there are a couple of times in the
latter part of the 20th century where we
made it through like the eye of a needle
we barely bloody well made it and the
Cuban Missile Crisis was one of those
points but the the early 80s things were
heating up pretty badly too you know in
about 1984 there was a movie that came
out called the day after Prague guys
probably don't know about the day after
but it was the most-watched movie that
had ever been broadcast on TV at that
point and basically what it showed this
what a city would be like the day after
the United States had been bombed into
total desolation by a Soviet missile
attack and you know it was a pretty
hair-raising movie and one of the things
that was quite interesting about it was
that Ronald Reagan later said that he
watched that movie and that was actually
part of the reason that he entered into
day Tom talks with with Soviets now you
know Reagan had been basically scaring
the hell out of the Soviets he called
them an evil empire which liberals
weren't very happy about but the Soviets
man they were an evil empire there's
absolutely no doubt about it you know
it's not obvious how many people the
killed during their their communist
revolution and in the years following
that but the estimates range from twenty
to sixty million now that's a lot of
people like even if it's 20 million
that's three times as many people as
were killed in the Holocaust you know
the song the Soviet starved six million
Ukrainians in the 1930s and that was
just to get warmed up so the idea that
the Soviets were an evil empire it's
like it's a strong word but there's
absolutely no doubt that it was true and
the more we learn about what happened
especially during the stell in this
period although Lenin was no picnic you
know he he pretty much created the
Stalinist monster that followed him the
more we learn about it the more horrible
it becomes you know and the Soviet
system was was operated the economy
fundamentally ran on slave labor you
know for what economy there was and you
know what happened with Reagan in part
was well first of all the Soviet Union
was falling apart because there's just
so long you can keep a sinking ship
afloat you know and something that big
can die 20 years before it falls over
you know a system like that can stumble
along half gutted and and still manage
and so by the time Reagan come along the
thing it probably pretty much burned
itself out as a consequence of internal
contradictions but he ramped up the
American military spending to a
staggering degree and part of the idea
behind that at least that's what the
Republicans would have everyone believe
and it might be true was that they're
just going to spend the Russians right
into bankruptcy and they basically did
and so that was that for the Soviet
Union that it fell over 1989 which was
like that was a good day that was a
really good day and the weird thing is
no one saw it coming
you know and that was that was that was
shocking it was like one day the Soviet
Union was there in the next day the
Soviet Union is gone and there are no
CIA analysts that said hey yeah they're
about ready to crumble you know you just
have to blow on them and they'll fall
over it was a shock to everyone you know
and then it was very iffy in the
aftermath whether or not it would hold
Yeltsin who was a terrible drunkard but
actually a pretty courageous while he
was a Russian you know he was a pretty
courageous guy and he faced down
reestablishment by the totalitarians on
a tank you know
that was good for him because that was
pretty frightening too anyways I'm
telling you all this because when I grew
up most of the people I knew were
convinced that there was no bloody way
we're going to make it to the 20th
century you know and I think I can
remember discussing this with all of my
friends frequently you know and um you
know some people kind of use that as an
excuse not to get their life together
like you know what the hell is the point
you know we're going to blow ourselves
up anyways so you know I muscle drink
vodka til I fall over and you know
that's not particularly a moral way of
looking at it but I'll tell you like
there was no shortage of thinking that
this was so insane that it was going to
Syria certainly end in absolute
catastrophe and it damn near did like it
wasn't some kind of collective delusion
you know there there were times in fact
there was a story recently published
about a Russian general who was given
the order to launch the missiles there
was a mistake in reading on their
display showing that missiles were
coming from North America across the
poles into Russia and he was told to
launch and he didn't it's like well good
for him you know but that's a little too
close really you know and there's all
sorts of other crazy things that
happened during that period of time so
for example I read this book by an
ex-kgb guy who said he worked in a
biological warfare lab in the Soviet
Union
they'd killed a number of people by
accident when some of their bugs got out
you know on the order of 500 people
which is a lot of people but it's not
even like 250,000 people but it's a lot
of people but what those geniuses were
trying to do was to cross Ebola smallpox
smallpox
so smallpox is unbelievably the
combination of smallpox in Ebola is
extraordinarily easy to transmit and
very very very fatal and so they were
trying to cross it and then aerosolize
it so that you could distribute it in
canisters and blow it over cities you
know a nice bit of scientific
investigation perfectly reasonable
scientific question can it be done
little sketchy on the moral side you
might
so you know it was a pretty crazy period
of time and I mean all human history
what did what a dusty s you say about
human history the one thing you can say
about it that it's not rational right he
said the very word sticks in your throat
so you know it's always being crazy and
it's crazy now but it was really crazy
then and so we got through that and
thank God you know as far as I'm
concerned the world is a lot better
place now than it was well it is 30
years ago 40 years ago 50 years ago
things are way better now you know you
hear a lot of doom and gloom about how
we're going to destroy the planet but
but we probably aren't you know the
population is going to stabilize out at
about 9 billion that's what the
projections look like we already have
about seven we can handle another two
there's kind of there's going to be some
extinctions we're eating up the ocean
like insane you know piranhas that's
mostly a fault of public policy but it
looks like we're probably going to
squeak through the century with a bit of
damage and then things will settle down
you know it's highly probable if there's
anything vaguely human left in a hundred
years that the big problem will be that
population is rapidly decreasing you
know that's already happening in
European countries it's happening in
Japan it's going to happen in China so
by the year 2100 the most populous
country in the world is going to be
Nigeria not China so China is going to
lose people like mad because they had a
one-child policy right and everybody in
China is getting also you know that it's
not going to be hyper populated so
anyways so I was interested in all this
because you know I kind of felt that I'd
grown up I didn't feel like I'd grown up
under its shadow I'd grown up under its
shadow you know and it was something in
the back of our minds all the time and
then there was a question underneath
that a couple of them and one was how
why is this possible how is this
possible how could it be that the world
could divide itself up into two armed
camps like hyper armed camps right tens
of thousands of nuclear missiles more
than enough to wipe out the enemy many
times over I don't remember what the
American Arsenal peeked at but I think
it was more than 50,000 nuclear weapons
like I don't know if there are 50,000
towns in the Soviet Union you know maybe
they were going to bomb Moscow 50 times
thing but after the first two or three
it was probably more or less irrelevant
so it was really it was really crazy you
know and I don't know if you know this
but and I believe this was during the
Kennedy era I hope I've got this right
one of Kennedy's genius boys came up
with the because Kennedy's
administration was run by a lot of
Harvard graduates and Ivy League
graduates and so you know they were
supposed to be pretty intelligent but
intelligence and wisdom are not the same
thing but anyways they established a
policy which was called mutual assured
destruction which means if you hit me I
kill you and then you kill me and so
it'd be better if we just didn't bother
and the acronym was mad right mutual
assured destruction it's like you know
just thinking about that it's a chilling
thought it's like what horrible entity
thought that up as a joke it only you
think well is that some sense that some
politicians idea of whiffed but where'd
that come from
so that's a hell of a thing to make a
joke about you know mad well that was
right it was definitely mad you know and
the odd thing is is that we didn't blow
ourselves up and we didn't have a third
world war and you know you you can't
make a solid claim that the event of
nuclear weapons was necessarily the
worst thing that could have happened you
know because even the Soviets who were
completely insane and of course the
Maoist who probably even worse they
weren't insane enough to start a nuclear
war now Stalin there's evidence there's
debate about it but there was a there's
evidence that Stalin was basically
murdered partly by Khrushchev was who
was his who was his successor when
Stalin died Khrushchev and three other
people were in his house and what
happened in Stalin's house the night he
died is not clear but I read a book
recently called Stalin interestingly
enough that was written by a guy who had
access to the full Communist Party
archives you know which was relatively
new thing and that was his conclusion
and he also believed that Stalin was
gearing up to do it an invasion of
Europe and he that he didn't give a damn
how many cities would have to be bombed
in order for the Soviets to roll through
and Stalin he was like that you know
Stalin was perfect at cape
full of taking entire Nations of people
out in Eastern Europe by train and
shipping them out to Siberia in the
middle of the winter with nothing to eat
and no tools and letting them live which
of course they didn't and that meant
women children men you know shorn of all
their belongings and thrust out into the
middle of nowhere to perish or or live
as they saw fit and if they perished so
much the better as far as Stalin was
concerned and so he wasn't exactly the
sort of person the idea of a nuclear war
would necessarily stop and it's
certainly possible that that's what he
was hoping for you know because when we
look at people like Stalin and Hitler we
think well you know they're after world
domination you know and you think well
in some sense that's kind of a positive
motivation right I mean no really but
it's like if you have a Corvette say and
someone steals it you can think well I
know why they stole it that they want to
have the Corvette you know it's it's an
understandable motivation to want power
it's not necessarily an admirable one
although sometimes power is a perfectly
reasonable thing to pursue but I don't
have any idea why we ever assumed that
those guys were after victory like you
should never make the presupposition
that everyone is out to win some people
are out to lose and the more people they
can take with them the better you know
and when Hitler died he committed
suicide in a bunker way down below
Berlin while Berlin was on fire in
Europe was burning it's like as far as I
can tell that was exactly what Hitler
was after right from the beginning you
know he was interested in fire as a
purifying agent you know he's a fire
worshipper in some sense because if you
look at the nuremberg gatherings of the
nazis you know they're spectacular
spectacular celebrations unbelievably
dramatic and impressive and they've
frequently featured fire and fires of
purifying agent you know and hitler by
the end of world war ii was he was
pretty contemptuous of the germans
because they really hadn't served him
well that wasn't like he thought well
maybe it wasn't such a good idea to
start a whole second world war you know
because it was a little on the
narcissistic side we might say but by
the time the russians came marching in
and germany was in ruins hitler was
perfectly happy to have the Allies trump
all over the citizens because that's
what they deserved
anyways and so that's the sort of guy he
was and so why we would assume that he
wanted to win just because that's what
he said is something I've never been
able to understand you know the kids who
shot up Columbine didn't want to win
I wanted to kill as many people as
possible to make a point and then they
wanted to kill themselves just in case
you didn't exactly get the point and the
point was the more destruction the
better and if I have to go along with
that hey no problem that just makes me a
little bit more serious that I might
have otherwise be and so those sorts of
motivations are not pleasant to
understand but we have enough
documentation about events like that you
know especially the mass killings those
guys have written down exactly why they
do it now I have some excellent books on
extraordinarily vengeful map serial
killers and mass murderers I know
exactly how they think there's a great
book if you're interested in this sort
of thing called panzram PA n z ra m and
carl panzram was a serial killer and
rapist who live pretty much early in the
20th century and he was a tough
delinquent he sort of kid from a large
family and when he was you know 13 14
they sent him off to some reform school
and it was written by the same sort of
people that run Canada's residential
schools and you know so those were
basically predators on children and of
course he was raped and and and and
brutalized and tormented and in all
sorts of horrible ways and but he was a
tough guy and when he came out he
decided that you know the human race
really wasn't worth that much and that
he was going to wreak as much mayhem as
he possibly could for the rest of his
life he raped a thousand men he killed
dozens of people he kept track of the
dollar value of the buildings he burned
down like this was a serious guy and he
wasn't he was bent on destruction and
that's that what is what were his dying
words first of all there was a committee
I believe of women who intervened on
behalf of him because they were anti a
capital punishment and he said to them
if I remember correctly that he wished
the human race had won neck so that he
could put his hands around it and
squeeze so you know that was his way of
pointing out to the
who didn't think that maybe capital
punishment was justified in his case
that maybe they weren't thinking clearly
and then to the hangman he said hurry up
you who's your bastard I could kill ten
men in the time it takes you to hang me
so you know you don't get a statement
like that from someone who isn't
thoroughly committed to what he's doing
so the situation in that the world found
itself involved in really had me
thinking you know part of it was well
what the hell is going on with all these
weapons and how can it possibly be that
anyone thinks that that's a reasonable
solution and how did it come about that
this could even occur and what are we
thinking and then so there was that and
then there was also the why are people
so damn convinced on each side of this
argument that they're right enough to
risk everything for you know which is a
perfectly good question and then there
was the malevolence issue like how much
of this has nothing to do with wanting
to see your side win and everything to
do with wanting to see everything lose
you know and then ah then there was
another issue which was well are both
sides wrong are both sides right because
that's more of a cultural relativist
approach right it's like yeah yeah the
Communists believe one thing in the
bloody capitalists believe another and
they're just as bad who wit you like who
believes what is completely arbitrary
because belief systems are arbitrary and
so maybe they're both right or they're
both wrong and I thought well either of
those conclusions was pretty damn dismal
because if they're both right then well
what are you going to do have them talk
it out I don't think so and if they're
both wrong well that's not much better
and then if one's right and the other is
wrong well does that mean anything like
is it possible for one belief system to
be more right than another belief system
because of course that's certainly not a
tenant of moral relativism and you might
think about that as the standard
certainly the standard intellectual
approach to morality and probably has
been for the last hundred years I think
by the way that that's a reprehensible
morality and what I'll tell you why as
the course might as we move through the
course because one of the things I tried
to find out was was what we were
fighting for you know
assuming that you give the West a bit of
the benefit of the doubt and assume that
some of the things that we stand for we
actually stand for and aren't just you
know posturing and parading was that
grounded in anything or was it just
arbitrary opinion so that's what we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about why people believe the things they
believe what psychological function the
beliefs perform we're going to talk
about malevolence and as far as I can
tell like malevolence is the willingness
to do evil and I think the best is the
best definition of evil and I thought
about this for a long time like actually
what constitutes evil it's complicated
we'll talk about a lot but I think if
you want a one-line summary it's the
desire to do harm for the sake of the
harm so you have to think about it as a
kind of art form so like if you're look
if you have a terrorist and you think
he's hidden an atom bomb in a stadium
and you think well he's not going to
tell me you have good evidence he's not
going to tell me unless I torture him I
don't think you should torture him
because torture is wrong but you know if
you're doing that and you really believe
he's hidden atom bomb in a stadium well
at least you have some justification for
what you're doing and it's not
necessarily that what you're doing is
evil it might be wrong it might be
misguided I mean who's to say in a
situation like that it should certainly
be illegal but at least you can say well
there's a plausible explanation for it
but lots of situations where there's
absolute horror there's no plausible
explanation for whatsoever so I can give
you an example so for example one of the
things that used to happen in our switz
if I remember correctly arsh wits I
don't know what you guys envision when
you envision concentration camps you
know like concentration camp it's a
funny name first of all because it's not
really a camp you know what I mean but a
concentration camp isn't like a prison
you know and that's easy too it's kind
of easy to envision them like a prison
those bloody things were cities right
they have tens of thousands of people in
them so they're massive at least they
were large towns so these are very big
places anyways you know at the typical
concentration camp the trains would come
rolling in and of course
people have been packed into the damn
trains like well worse than animals
they'd be packed standing and lots of
people just died in the cars because
especially if they were old or little in
or had some respiratory problem or
something like that because they'd
overheat if they were cramped right in
the middle of people are they'd freeze
to death on the outside because they're
pushed right against the wood or you
know but that was okay it just made the
job easier when they finally landed at
Auschwitz you know and then once they
were in Auschwitz well then the guards
used to like to play tricks on them and
so one trick would be to get some poor
son-of-a-bitch who you know being torn
away from his country who'd had his
family destroyed who knew where he was
going who was half dead for six
different reasons who was among
strangers maybe he didn't even speak or
she didn't even speak the language that
was most common there you know guarded
by absolutely ruthless barbarians who
wanted to do nothing else but make
people as miserable as possible it is in
the most creative possible ways and so
what they would do with some of the
prisoners would they give them wet sacks
of salt and so those weigh about a
hundred pounds and they'd have them
carry for them from one side of the
compound to the other well you know
that's not so bad when you're really
really innovative in your capacity to
perpetrate evil but the next thing they
did was carry them back and so you think
about that you know and this is
something you have to understand if you
really want to understand evil is that
it's an aesthetic it's an art form you
know and the reason that that was such a
terrible torture was well partly because
these people were already ruined and 100
pounds is a lot of salt and maybe it was
winter and they didn't have any shoes
and you know like it's just through the
labor but Solzhenitsyn when he wrote
about the Gulag Archipelago he said you
know even if you were a prisoner they
were having you build a wall you could
at least take some damn pride in
building the wall you know you could lay
some bricks out you could think well
this sucks and that's really horrible
and everything but you know I built a
straight wall that's something but if
you have to take a sack of wet salt to
one side of the compound and then carry
it back like the net consequence of that
is zero right it's zero and of course
the famous signs on the outside of the
concentration camps where work will set
you free right now that's another joke
it's like mutual assured destruction you
know and the only way you can you know a
joke like that is satanic there's no
other way to think about it a joke like
that comes out of the deepest depths of
human malevolence and then the work that
sets you free well it wasn't even work
right it was it was a parody of work and
the purpose of the work was to destroy
you but not quickly because that's not
as terrible as destroying you slowly you
know so these are very very terrible
things and so part of what I thought
about in relationship to people's belief
systems was you know people are
territorial
chimps you know I don't know if you know
this or not but chimps basically go to
war Jane Goodall discovered that a
couple of decades ago that really really
was hard on her because she was kind of
a Russo Ian so for those of you don't
know John Jacques Rousseau is a French
philosopher and you know French
philosophers have a lawful lot of sins
on their conscience and of course we so
is certainly one of them because
Rousseau was the first like what fully
articulate promoter of the idea that
human beings were basically good so you
know we had a good soul in a moral sense
but we were corrupted by her social
institutions you know so so you know as
far as Rousseau was concerned it was
kind of a noble savage idea you know
like the human being in their raw form
has a pure soul and then you know you
give them to parents and you give them
to teachers and you know they get into
politics and there's group disputes and
then they get all corrupted you know and
well you know that's I don't even want
to say about that except that it's
absolutely you know but it's it's
the appealing proposition if you're
naive optimist I mean first of all it
doesn't explain where malevolence comes
from because the people created the
institution so you know it just puts you
into an infinite regress chicken-and-egg
if the institutions are reprehensible
but the people who built them aren't
then where did the reprehensible
elements of the institutions come from
you know he might think it's an auto
generating consequence of organizing
people but you know it's a pretty
specious theory so I'm of course he had
a counter
art of philosophical counterpart Thomas
Hobbes and Hobbes said basically exactly
the opposite that you know people were
vicious and cruel unless you like put
them in straightjackets fundamentally
and made them obey then everything was
going to go immediately to hell you know
and when when you saw what happened in
Iran after the Americans waltzed in and
the power structure disintegrated you
know it was a hell of a lot more like
Hobbes and it was like Rousseau right
you took out the tyrant at the top and
it wasn't like everybody got all
peaceful and loving all of a sudden it
was like absolute chaos reigned so you
know of course you can rationalize that
but anyways Rousseau by the way had five
children by a maid illiterate maid that
it was his mistress he put every single
one of them in orphanages where of
course they perished because orphanages
at Rousseau's times were not exactly you
know a luxury resort and even up till
the beginning of the 20th century most
children who were under 1 years of age
who were in care institutions died
partly disease and that sort of thing
but often because they just weren't
touched they weren't cared for
physically even if they were fed and you
know 200 years ago they weren't even fed
so anyway so you know but nonetheless
you know people have people maintain the
optimistic idea that human beings were
you know basically good and that they
were corrupted by institutions it's a
common idea among I think it's a very
common idea in the universities you know
because University people are always
complaining about the corrupt nature of
this institution in that institution you
know well they sit here in the warm with
the electricity on you know it's
surrounded by wealth that characterizes
maybe 1/10 of 1% of the entire world's
population and you know they complain
about how oppressed they are and how you
know nasty the institutions are it's
like you know well you actually haven't
been to a nasty institution you know
because nasty institutions they get
pretty damn bad and most of the
institutions in the world are like that
so it isn't exactly clear that people
are pristine in their heart and then
corrupted by institutions and although
I'm sure that happens happen to pans
around for example so anyways this has
been a line of philosophical speculation
that's that's that
I would say constituted one of the
unspoken fundamental assumptions of of
Western intellectuals in particular and
Jane Goodall thought you know in many
ways the same way she thought chimps
were basically you know they're just
animals they're okay they exist to exist
relatively peacefully with one another
you know even Carl Rogers who I talked
about a bit of my personality class you
know he basically thought that people
were fundamentally good and that
institutions made them bad
but Tom the problem is you look at
chimps and they're a fair bit like us
you know barnable is you can look at
them too and they're they're genetically
quite related to us and they're quite a
bit different than chimps but so we're
sort of a weird mixture of the two in
some sense but chimps like those things
there is no evidence that they really
have any internal control over the
regression at all you know there was a
horrible case about two years ago where
a woman was interacting with the chimp
and it tore her to pieces and they can
do that back like it took her face right
off and they have the strength of about
six men like an adult male chimp can
break a 300 pound test cable you know
those things are really really strong
and they're not friendly you know like
so in arnhem zoo for example there has
been a troop of chimps there that have
been followed by an extremely brilliant
par mythologist named Fran's de Waal
whose work I would very highly recommend
the wall is a very smart guy and he's
looked at the origins of morality in
chimpanzees you know from a biological
perspective very very nice work very
very clear-headed but you know he's
recounted absolutely horrific stories of
chimpanzee behavior so one of the
stories he talked about for example was
you know you kind of have this idea that
there's a male chimp hierarchy it's
roughly true there's a female hierarchy
too but the males in the chimp world
anyways tend to be the dominant ones and
you know you kind of think of a dominant
primate like a prizefighter you know
pretty much he's ruling because of his
physical prowess now that turns out not
to exactly be true but in this
particular case the guy who was running
the chimp troop was a bit of a bully and
he wasn't very good at making friends
you know and that's not such a good
idea because no matter how tough you are
by yourself to weaker guys can probably
take you out and that's what happened
during friends to was observations and
to chimps attack the leader and they had
a coalition they were grooming each
other they repels you know and chimps
are pretty good at remembering like
reciprocal relationships and having
friendships really like they have a very
highly social structure they just tore
him apart like the things they did to
him look like you don't even want to
talk about and so chimps have really no
upper limit on their capacity for
aggression and when they hunt because
chimps hunt and they like me
they often hunt colobus monkeys and they
weigh about 35 pounds like a colobus
monkeys a major-league animal and they
eat those things alive and they scream
while they're being killed and that does
not slow the chimps down one bit so it's
not obvious that the chimp is really a
creature of a lot of empathy especially
the males
the females are likely more empathic
because they have to deal with infants
for longer periods of time what seems to
inhibit the aggression of male chimps
isn't anything they hold internally it
seems that when they get hyper
aggressive in the truth the troop gets
more and more agitated and basically
shuts them down so you can imagine maybe
you're in a rough barn some dingbat
who's you know half psychopathic and has
had two pints of alcohol is starting to
cause a tremendous amount of trouble and
he's not going to show themself down but
the rest of the troop might and that
kind of means that the control over the
aggression is externalized it's not a
consequence of super-ego control and we
like to think that we actually control
our own aggression but I'm not so sure
about that
you know if you read things like there's
a great book a horrifying book published
about 20 years ago called The Rape of
Nanking which is while the woman who
wrote it committed suicide so that sort
of suffice us to tell you what The Rape
of Nanking is about and it's a story
about the Japanese in World War two
going into a Chinese Kitty city called
Nanking where I believe about 350,000
people were killed and the Nazis in that
story were the good guys so you can
imagine the kind of brutality that might
be occurring there but there's
absolutely perfectly well documented
evidence suggesting that the Japanese
soldiers engage in competitive brutality
you know and so really what happened was
the Japanese had been pretty militarized
by World War two and they'd adopted a
Prussian education system
and the Prussians at Germans you know
pre-pre 20th century Germans they were
basically interested in educating
obedient soldiers you know because it
was a militaristic culture and the
Japanese kind of adopt about because
they were sick of being kicked around by
the Europeans pretty successfully
because they defeated the Russians you
know in the early stages of rule or of
the 20th century was quite a shock to
everyone in Europe and you know cause
for great celebration and Japan and no
wonder but anyways they militarized the
hell out of their young men and taught
them basically that the Japanese were a
master race you know and that other
people were subhuman it's a very common
human way of thinking by the way I would
say it's really the default way that
human tribes think about other tribes
you know I mean it's a little more
complicated than that because human
tribes tend to trade with other tribes
so it's not all demonization but a lot
of it is you know and if you look around
the world in the anthropological
literature what you see is that the
names that most tribes have for
themselves is something like that human
beings or the people you know indicating
that the rest of the people are breeding
people God only they're barbarians or
you know they live out where the Sun is
being eaten by the dragon of the night
or something like that and you know the
word barbarian is a is a word that comes
from the Greeks making fun of how
non-greek spoke they you know they
thought they went bar bar bar bar bar
something like that
so anyways what good ol fun was that the
chimps like the chimp adolescents in
particular particularly the male's would
patrol the the borders of their
territory in groups of three or four and
with often with a female or two but the
females didn't seem to be reading the
the the they were they were more part of
the group rather than the initiators but
what the chimps would do is if they
found a chimp from another troop even if
that was a chimp that had moved from
their troop in the not-too-distant past
and joined another because sometimes the
male's leave and sometimes they go to
other troops if they outnumbered them
they would tear them to pieces and it
looked like that's why they were doing
the Border Patrol they're looking for
trouble their gangs roughly speaking
they're looking for trouble but the
point of it is is that and they would
only attack if they outnumbered
you know because chimps can I wouldn't
say they count
they have a rudimentary notion of group
size you know I don't think you can
count without being able to verbalize
but you can estimate at a glance and so
you know when I mean when I say tear
apart that's exactly what I mean
there's no upper limit on the brutality
and so Goodall discovered that first and
she didn't tell anybody about it now she
had her reasons I mean some of them I
think we're dialoguing oh the lovely
chimps you know and fair enough but some
of it was also she thought that maybe
the chimps had been corrupted as a
consequence of their contact with human
beings and that their natural behavior
had been somehow transformed you know
and that's not it's reasonable to be
cautious if you're a scientist before
you go out and say hey chimps go to war
isn't that revolutionary because it is
right because it just it just ends the
idea that our warlike and malevolent
nature is a function of culture like if
chimps do it well what are they
perverted by their own culture I don't
think so you know I mean there are more
and less violent chimp cultures and
there are more and less violent baboon
cultures so there's some cultural
variation but since Goodall time this
sort of behavior is being documented on
many many chimp troops so that's us in a
nutshell and it's not self-evident that
if you put the typical adolescent male
say who's not a very well formulated
personality and you you know eat because
he's not that individual and and you
know he hasn't seen much of the world
and the typical guy that goes into the
army is you know he's kind of on the
margins of society maybe he's not
particularly bright and I'm not trying
to be insulting by that but you know
it's not exactly a high-end job you put
someone that like that in a place where
there's no rules it's like who leads
where there are no rules well the
probability that it's the friendliest
and nicest people is very very low and
so what seemed to happen in Nanking was
the Japanese soldiers took their cues
from the people with the most brutal
imaginations so you know when people can
have pretty brutal imaginations
especially when they start to compete so
so I was interested in that hill what
exactly was at the core of that
malevolence
I mean and I think it is uniquely human
the chimps will go tear another chip
part but basically they just they're
just they're gonna kill them you know
that's their goal and maybe it takes a
while but it's not going to take for
weeks
whereas if you're a human being you know
you can draw out your enemies death for
a very very long period of time and part
of that is the desire to produce the
misery and suffering that's attendant on
the death and only human beings have the
imagination to do that that's why I
think and we'll return to this that's
why I think that in the book of Genesis
when people's eyes are open and they
become self conscious they always all
always also learn the difference between
good and evil once your eyes are open
and you know what you're like once you
know you're naked and vulnerable then
you can exploit that in other people and
only human beings have that kind of
knowledge so the fact that we know that
we can be hurt makes us particularly
dangerous because if I know how I can be
hurt I sure know how you can be hurt so
you know it's a nasty situation and then
of course I'm kind of interested in the
motivation for that so you know you look
at the Columbine kids for example and
you know the mayhem they produce was
trivial compared to the mayhem they were
planning you know if it was up to those
two guys they would have bombed Detroit
flat that you know they had visions of
doing exactly that and it was a media
spectacular and they didn't do it
because they were you know poor kids in
some sense who were bullied that is an
idiotic explanation it's not true you
know everybody's a bloody outsider you
know I mean I'm sure there isn't a
single one of you that don't have a
memory from junior high where you were
an outcast in one way or another maybe
some of you weren't but it's very very
common and to think of that as
sufficient motivation to you know shoot
people cold-bloodedly in high schools
sorry that's a little on the naive side
so I'm very very interested in what
makes up that motivation you know
because malevolence Plus nuclear weapons
is not a good combination and so it
doesn't really look to me like we can
afford that kind of unconscious
malevolence anymore because we're just
too damn powerful and if the wrong
person ends up being like that with the
wrong weapons is like games over so I've
also become convinced while I'd be
looking through this that the problem
that we're discussing is not a
sociological problem
or a political problem or an economic
problem because you know a lot of what
you read a lot of political scientists
tell you this sort of thing because
they're basically almost always closeted
Marxists they'll tell you that the
reason for for struggle for competition
between nations is economic and I think
that's absurd not because it isn't true
but because it doesn't actually address
a more fundamental issue which is okay
well economic struggle is a struggle
about who has access to what's valued
but there's nothing self-evident about
what's valued that's the problem it's
like you know you have the idea of
natural resource it's like yeah oil is
not a natural resource till you have an
automobile you know I mean the interplay
between cultural values structures and
what constitutes a natural resource is
so tightly put together except for maybe
air and water that saying well there are
natural resources which means things of
intrinsic value and that's what people
fight over well you you made the mystery
mystery disappear inside the word
natural resource but you haven't solved
anything so the question is well why
would people fight over things that they
value well because there's all sorts of
things you could value like peace for
example so it's not a sufficient
explanation and and it's also not clear
to me that people's primary motivations
are economic you know it's one element
of motivation is not trivial but I would
say the motivation isn't even really
economic it's more related to dominance
hierarchy position and that's
fundamentally a sexual motivation
especially for men because if Lander
higher up in the dorm male dominance
hierarchy then women are much more
attracted to them so you could make you
could say well that's economics I don't
think it is surface economic is it's
just a secondary consequence of that and
I don't believe by the way that that's a
theory because there's excellent
documentation on hyper aggression and
adolescent males and the best evidence
suggests that adolescent males become
hyper aggressive when you put them in
situations where they can't win and then
they become hyper aggressive in an
attempt to formulate a dominance
hierarchy so that some of them can rise
to the top and basically be attractive
so
you can call that economic if you want
but I think it's I think you're pushing
your luck with that sort of explanation
so well so that's basically the
background so when I was investigating
this I first started studying political
science you know and I actually liked
that quite a bit in the first couple of
years because I was basically reading
political philosophy you know and it's
actually worthwhile reading great
political philosophers because they they
could think and that's a really good
thing and be you think like they think
even if you don't know it right because
one of the hallmarks of a great
philosopher is that his ideas or her
ideas sink into the culture so deeply
that like 100 years after they've
written everybody just thinks they
always thought that way like that's one
of the things say that's happened to
Freud I mean everybody kind of
understands that there's an unconscious
and the people are motivated by sexual
you know by a sexual drive it's like
what so you know what's so brilliant
about that like well yeah it's obvious
when stroy points it out so
so anyways I started you know I took
political science first and literature
which I thought was also extremely
useful because great literary people
have great things to say like
Dostoyevsky I mean what his novels just
absolutely flattened me he's so
brilliant and I've never read any one
who takes moral questions so seriously
like so for example if you look at crime
and punishment which is a book I would
highly recommend Dostoevsky is the
absolute model of a true intellectual
and I say that because in crime and
punishment for example Dostoyevsky has
this character named Raskolnikov and you
guys could identify with risk Olenick
off to some degree because he's about
your age and he's a university student
now he's out in a rough time because
he's in st. Petersburg and he doesn't
have any money and he lives in this tiny
little room which has you know basically
a bunch of clothes on the bed that he
can sleep in and he's starving to death
can only has bread to eat he's a law
student so he's having a rough time you
know in st. Petersburg the end of the
19th century is kind of a rough place so
he has it some of you guys probably have
is pretty bad but what's called the
cough had it pretty bad and so he's half
starved didn't half delirious and and
he's also very his ideas are very addled
because he's one of the first Russians
who really considered themselves an
atheist so you know Russia was a
medieval society until the late 1900s
was sort of like Quebec before 1954 1960
and I'm serious about that because
Quebec was really the last European
country so to speak that underwent a
secularization and that happened in in
about 1960 and Quebec families went from
an average size of about 12 to 13 to 1.2
lowest birth rate in the world and the
call they came back while were married
and none of them are now and they were
all Catholic and hardly any of them are
now and was an overnight transformation
and that's partly what fed Quebec
nationalism because it was actually a
study that was or a study that was
released by a Gallup Organization I only
heard it referred to in one meeting that
where they indicated that if you were
lapsed Catholic in Quebec you were 10
times more likely to be a separatist
that's really worth thinking about right
because religion collapses and what
since nationalism just rises up to to
take its place because you need a bloody
belief structure because what else what
are you gonna do wander around aimlessly
that's not fun it's not useless or
useful you know so you just jump from
one structure of belief to another or
you fall apart so so that's also
something that's very much worth knowing
anyway so Albert Skolnick oov he thinks
he's a pretty educated guy and he's
pretty smart and he is pretty smart but
he's like smart arrogant not smart wise
because he's 21 what the hell does he
know he doesn't know anything but he's
smart and he's contemptuous of other
people because he can probably smarter
than most of them you know and he
confuses that without with knowing
what's going on and so he lives in this
little horrible apartment and he has a
horrible landlady and she really like
this is where Dostoyevsky said genius
like what Skolnick of hates his landlady
and then Dostoyevsky tells you why and
you'd think well yeah I'd hate her too
so she's miserable
she owns a bunch of apartments she
charges too much rent for them she
tortures all the people that rent from
her in every possible way she can the
places her filthy she doesn't provide
any furniture she hoards money and
doesn't do anything with it so she lives
in absolute poverty and you know and and
in filth and she's a cruel person in
every possible way plus she has this
niece who isn't very bright you know
it's intellectually impaired and she
basically treats her like a slave so
she's not doing anyone any good and
that's what Skolnick loves her and then
he gets a letter from his mother and his
mother basically tells him that his
sister is going to go marry this rich
guy because she's in love with him and
that'll solve all of his monetary
problems so he can keep going to law
school but he reads between the lines
and you know he realizes pretty quickly
that this like rich guy is a real like
miserly scum rat and he's going to treat
his sister and his mother absolutely
miserably and his sister doesn't really
love him anyways and the only reason
she's marrying him so that risk all
knock-off can go to school so he's not
very happy with that and you know fair
enough you know you can understand his
motivation so he's starving and he's
full of these ideas also there's sort of
Nietzschean you know so was
and like atheistic ideas hit Russia
really hard because it went from
seriously Orthodox Christian in every
possible way to unbelievably skeptical
in one generation and it just it just
fractured the society it's partly why
communism became so absolutely
attractive for the Russians and
Dostoyevsky also details that extremely
brilliantly in a book called the
possessed or The Devil's so it's a
wonderful book it's hard to get into you
have to read about 200 pages before it
really kicks in but you know that's
Russian almost sort of like that
so anyways Raskolnikov is he's thinking
these sort of super mannish
rationalistic ideas and he thinks well
you know there's no evidence that
there's any real moral hierarchy and you
can easily make a case that the reason
that people aren't really moral they're
just cowardly and this is a Nietzsche
and observation right most of what you
call your morality isn't morality all
it's just you're too afraid to do what
you want and because you're too weaselly
to admit that you say that you don't do
those things because your moral but it
isn't true you'd love to do them if you
were brave enough you just aren't so
people miss read that to say that what
Nietzsche thought was that all morality
was cowardice that isn't what he thought
he thought that all cowardice
masqueraded as morality that's a whole
different thing
so anyways recalls Raskolnikov is
thinking about these things and he's
thinking well I could be a lawyer and
I'd be a good one I'd help people I'd
help the poor people you know and what
the hell good is it for me to wander
around starving like this and doesn't
seem reasonable and and my sister's
going to go basically prostitute herself
for this rich guy and that sucks and
like there's my landlady and she's an
absolutely reprehensible creature and
everyone agrees and she's old and worn
out and it's like and she has this
person she keeps as a slave oh maybe I
should just get rid of her and what I
love about that is that like this
happens almost all the time
in universities I would say but really
between whenever you hear people who
think they're smart have a discussion
what they generally do is they have an
idea and then they have an idea about
the person who has a different idea and
the idea about the person who has a
different idea is
their ideas stupid and so what they do
is they produce a caricature of that
person's idea and then they blast it and
they think wow I won that argument which
is really it's pathetic
it's a straw man argument it's the sign
of a weak mind what you do if you really
want to have an argument with someone is
you help them like let's say you're a
right winger and you're arguing with the
left wing or you're a left wing or
you're arguing with the right winger
it's like you want to make their
argument as magnificent as you possibly
can and then see if you can undermine it
that's what you do because then you're
getting somewhere like any idiot can
make a strongman and light it
Dostoevsky never does that he makes the
people that he's like when he sets up
two ideas to to go to war he embodies
both sets of ideas in the most powerful
characters he could imagine so in the
Brothers Karamazov for example the two
people the two protagonists basically
there's a bunch of them but one is named
Billy OSHA and the other is named Ivan
and Alyosha is kind of an innocent guy
good guy fundamentally little on the
naive side religious but not in a way
that he can defend you know it's more of
a natural expression of spirit and he's
in a monastery and he's the follower of
this famous monk and you know he's kind
of into Orthodox Christianity and his
benevolent and sincere way he's not much
of an intellect and Ivan his older
brother like Ivan's got everything he's
good-looking he's tall I believe he's a
soldier like he's an impressive guy and
he's got a viciously cutting intellect
and he just tears Eliana apart every
chance he gets
across the whole book and you know you
can see docked to parts of Dostoyevsky
fighting it out in the book because part
of Dostoyevsky was highly spiritual eyes
not least because he was epileptic and
that often for reasons we'll talk about
later that often exaggerated
spirituality but also because he was
like he was a deeply spiritual person
and also a tremendous intellect and so
he was at war inside and he put those
parts of a mote into these characters
and let them just go at it and it's
brilliant you know Ivan makes the
best argument for atheism that's ever
being written it's really powerful you
know he taught basically what he does is
he talks about all these terrible things
that were being done to children in
Russia at the turn of the century back
in the late 1918 OS you know he talks
about this one situation where the
parents of this young girl locked her in
a freezing outhouse overnight and she
was crying and screaming you know and
telling them that she was sorry and they
just left her in there and she froze to
death and it was like front-page news
and in Russia the time I guess probably
in Moscow or maybe in st. Petersburg
Dostoevsky lifted that argument then he
said - he had Ivan ask Elly oh she's
like okay well this is the sort of thing
God permits okay
he said the whole damn world isn't worth
that the suffering of one child in a
situation like that how can you possibly
see that something like that can exist
and warned around with your boneheaded
belief in a benevolent God what's up
with you would you like a girl in the
house overnight and let her freeze if
that meant that other people would be
happy you know and of course Ellie
elosha says well no I would never do
that
and so Ivan tells him well yeah you know
you wouldn't do that but this God that
you imagine exists would be perfectly
pleased to let something like that occur
you know Alyosha has no idea what to say
about God and Ivan not you know that's
just a fragment of Ivan's argument he's
like punching Adam like math you know
and I think the way Alyosha basically
responds is by trying to live a good
life you know he can't he can't argue
Ivan's better at it than he isn't plus
there's this vicious strain of critical
thinking about religion religion that's
being wafted in from Western Europe you
know there's 300 years of philosophical
force behind it and Ivan is expose it's
like Le OSHA and Russia itself is just
blown apart by that they have no defense
against that you know the bloody Western
Europeans had 300 years to get used to
it
the Russians had like 10 years so it
just fright fragmented them you know and
they were like waiting for the new
Messiah and they sure got one
and both Dostoyevsky underneath you
prophesied about what would happen in
Russia 40 years before it happened
that's bloody amazing to be to think
that you could look that far
future and actually get it right you
know I mean things didn't change quite
as fast as they are now but you know it
wasn't like Victor Victoria times were
static you know there are a lot of
things going on and so to get that right
over four decades it's those guys were
in touch with something very deep that
was going on underneath the substrata of
Western civilization so alright so you
know I'm thinking about belief
structures and I'm thinking about
malevolence and I'm thinking about the
psychological rule that these sorts of
things are playing you know because it
occurred to me at some point something
like an idea something like this and
this actually tormented me for about six
months I would say when I'd been
thinking these things through and I
guess it was for probably five years at
this point and I was really obsessed by
it was thinking about this literally
every minute of the day from the time I
woke up till the time I went to sleep it
was really manic probably but so I got I
got at one point I got to this
conclusion I thought okay well here's
the situation it's pretty obvious that
people need belief structures because
first of all a belief structure Orient's
them to action right so you have to
believe that one thing is more valuable
than another just to ask right so why
did the chicken cross the road well it's
because he thought the other side of the
road was better than the side he was on
obviously you know because whenever
you're moving the implicit hypothesis of
your movement is that the thing you're
moving towards is better than the thing
you're leaving them you know unless
you're self destructive because
otherwise why bother and so what that
means is you don't move without a value
structure and you don't get to not have
one you might say well I don't believe
in anything
so no no you say you don't believe in
anything so technically you can't make
an argument for what you believe or you
don't know what you believe but if
you're not just sitting there vegetating
then you believe something because
otherwise because you you act it out
right so
you have to have a belief system or Ori
fall apart right so your nihilistic or
depressed or hopeless not certainly like
who wants that that's not good that's
painful
depression is no joke you know I know
someone who had a very very serious
illness you know it was an illness that
destroyed parts of this person's body
destroyed their joints and they were
also had clinical depression and I asked
this person at one point okay you get to
get you get to have a choice you can get
rid of the illness that's destroying
your joints so they had to be replaced
or you can get rid of the depression
they said I get rid of the depression
first no problem so that's worth
thinking about
right so if you believe nothing you're
hopeless you've got no value structure
the place you end up is not good and I'm
sure lots of you have experienced that
you know I mean most people especially
the people who are likely to come to
this class most people by the time
they're your age have gone through a
dark period or two you know for whatever
reason relationship breaks up or maybe
you lose the meaning in your life or
someone betrays you or someone gets sick
or you get sick or you know some tragedy
comes along and knocks you flat you
think what the hell what's going on why
is any of this worthwhile and it's a
good question okay but you can't go
there because that's like death well
then the other problem is well let's say
you do have a belief system all right so
what happens if I have a different one
what are we supposed to do about that
you can't give up yours
cuz didn't you're done I think not going
to give up mine for the same reason but
it isn't clear that we can inhabit the
same part of the earth peacefully if we
don't believe the same things so I
wouldn't I sort of doubt it I thought oh
well that's it man we're basically
that's it we're done because you can't
not have a belief system and if you have
one you can't not fight and we're too
well-armed to fight now and we're not
just going to collapse into nihilism
although you know that happens quite a
bit so games over well it turned out
that that was wrong thank God but it
took me an awful long time to even begin
to understand how it could possibly be
wrong because as far as I could tell
those were the options
so another thing we're going to try to
figure out is not only you know exactly
why it people have belief systems
exactly what a belief system is and why
they compete and why you can't just get
rid of them but we're also going to
figure out what it is that you might be
able to do about the fact that you're
going to inhabit places with people who
don't have exactly the same belief
system as you you know and in some sense
it's really the problem of social being
right and creatures have been trying to
solve this problem ever since well we
don't know for how long I'd like to use
lobsters as an example because lobsters
arrange themselves into dominance
hierarchies and they have very complex
social behavior and they don't have much
of a brain so you can you can have
pretty damn complex social behavior
without having much of a brain lobsters
have been around for 400 million years
so us roughly speaking because we had
two shared ancestor with a lobster you
know a very long time ago we've been
trying to figure out how to coexist with
other creatures that don't precisely
share our belief systems for 400 million
years you know when we've been
sufficiently successful about it so that
we're both social and here we are so
obviously there's ways that it can be
dealt with although I don't think we
necessarily understand them very well
and part of so I didn't want to just
understand what it was about belief
systems you know about their necessity
and their function and the way that they
become pathologist I wanted to figure
out if there was also a pattern to the
processes by which belief systems are
modified and negotiated so that the
belief systems that have different
structures can coexist in the same place
peacefully it's a vital question right
because most of you are going to get
married
successfully you're unsuccessfully and
even if you don't you're going to live
with someone for a long period of time
and you're going to find out they're not
like you and that's extremely annoying
but you know what are you going to do
you're either going to be a slave or a
tyrant or you're going to negotiate
because those are your options and
negotiation is extraordinarily difficult
right because you have to figure out
what you want and probably won't even
admit it and second of all you have to
listen to your stupid partner telling
you what they want and then you have to
try to figure out how you're going to
both of them possible well slavery
tyranny that's comparatively easy from a
cognitive perspective compared to
actually trying to figure out how you
can be mutually satisfied in the same
space but you can do it that's the thing
there is a process and it's identifiable
so I want to talk to you about belief
systems and their psychological
significance what they're like what
function they perform but I also want to
talk to you about how they transform
because they do right they change
especially with humans so they can
change that means they can modify and
that means at least in principle that we
could have a dialogue now dialogues and
that's rough but the alternative is war
right and that's partly why you're
supposed to listen to your enemy because
if you don't listen to your enemy the
only other thing you can do is fight
with them that's it
you mean it's the desire for that to
happen yeah oh I would well I would say
it's partly the desire for that to
happen the thing is whenever I look at a
political movement especially
ideological build I think okay there's a
bunch of things here for fine what are
you against you know because one of the
things that people who adopt an
ideological position like to presume is
that all of the right is on their side
and that makes them very unconscious of
their shadow let's say from the Union
perspective the Nazis had all sorts of
positive reasons for what they were
doing but you know the negative reasons
were there too and you could easily make
it in that the negative reasons were
really the reasons and when I look at
India logs I always think yeah that's
what you're for sure but I don't believe
all the good people are on your side and
be I know that negative motivations are
more powerful than positive ones so you
say you're for things but you're against
them too so let's let's start with that
so I thought think I started thinking
about this after I read George Orwell I
love George Orwell by the way do you how
many of you know who George Orwell is
Wow really that's impressive
how many don't ok well that's that's
good that's amazing how the hell did you
learn about George Orwell is it 1984
fundamentally or animal farm animal farm
okay okay that's good because George
Orwell man I tell you George Orwell was
the first Western intellectual who
figured out what the hell was going on
in the Soviet Union and he did that in
the mid 40s early you know it was
complicated because we sort of knew what
was happening in the 20s and the 30s you
know there was Lenin and that wasn't so
good there was the Russian Civil War
there was the idea of universal
communism that wasn't such a good idea
you know for as far as people who didn't
want to be communist were concerned and
then there was what happened in the
Ukraine in the nineteen thirty so it was
like yeah you know the evidence was
starting to pile up but unfortunately
what happened was a Spanish Civil War
and the lefties were pretty much the
good guys in the Spanish Civil War right
it was like a microcosm of the Second
World War the lefties were fighting the
fascists and some of the lefties were
Carmen
but a lot of them were also people who
were I think genuinely fighting for
freedom and a lot of North American
literary figures went to Spain to fight
on the side of the know you know against
the fascists and so fair enough you know
the fascists were obviously you know
reprehensible clearly and so and so that
kind of muddied the water right because
the fascists were bad and then that sort
of means that people that are fighting
them they're good and some of them are
communists and there was good there was
pretty good reason for people to be
radically socialist at that point in
human history because the plight of the
working man was relatively unpleasant
George Orwell wrote a book called road
to Wigan Pier and he went up to this
town that was a coal mining town and he
he stayed with the coal miners for a
while and just looked at their life so
here here's part of their life so he
basically work a seven and a half hour
shift when you're a coal miner you think
oh that's not too bad by 1930 standards
it's like yeah except you have to go
down to the core mine tunnels you know
and like they're not eight feet high and
carpeted they're like four a half feet
high and rough and poorly lit and the
air is terrible and so basically you
have to chimp walk or crawl out to three
miles just to get to work and then you
have to do that at the end of your shift
and you don't get paid for that that's
just that's your commute right right so
you know it was no bloody well and then
of course what you're doing when you get
there is like it's absolutely filthy
it's unbelievably noisy it's brutally
difficult he said that coal miners they
have no teeth because they're like
because of their living conditions but
their bodies were absolutely perfect
they were unbelievably powerful and
strong because all they did was
incredibly intense physical labor but it
was bloody rough and the housing those
people had is like 50 families for one
outhouse that's probably good enough to
describe it and often they were row
houses and the row houses had no back
doors and they had no paths between them
and all the outhouses were at the back
so that meant if you were was like 20
blow in
the winter and you were sick then you
get to go all the way around the block
to your damn outhouse or maybe there's
only one there and you line up with 50
people so that you know yeah so and or
well he was or well was an upper-class
guy basically and he was trying to help
himself overcome his upper-class
prejudices and it was a real documentary
of the terrible working conditions of of
working-class people and he wrote this
book called road till we get Pierre but
one of the things that Orwell said he
wrote this story about these poor
goddamn coal miners and you think well
yeah it's like how about some social
legislation so that these people and
their children aren't just absolutely
brutalized non-stop no but then he wrote
the last half of the book and he wrote
it for the left book club which was a
socialist group that would publish a
book every month or so and what he did
was he wrote a critique of socialism of
pretty socialism and he said yeah how
this sucks man it's like we should be on
the side of these working people but the
Socialists I meet they're not on the
side of the working people they're like
tweed wearing middle-class hyper
intellectuals who never go anywhere near
the working class because of their class
prejudices and for all sorts of other
reasons and they don't like the poor at
all they just hate the rich and I
thought I had been a member of the NDP
for a long time at that point it was
always something a little off about it
especially the more radical endicott
what's with you guys like just it
doesn't look like benevolence as far as
I can tell there's a lot of whining and
complaining and resentment it's like
what that's what's that about I read or
what I thought aha right if you hate the
successful if you hate the rich who have
rich by the way is whoever has more
money than you like that's how you
define rich and the best way to mask
your resentment is to pretend that
you're on the side of the poor and are
you I read that I thought that's exactly
right and then that's part of also what
made me psychoanalytically oriented
because one thing psychoanalysts always
do always is if you say you're here's
how I'm positively predisposed the
psychoanalyst says how are you using
that to mask something
easy and malevolent that you're doing
and that's always that's a very very
useful questions not always correct
right but but it's correct a lot more
than people generally like to think you
know it's like the mother and grab the
mother or the winch and Hansel and
Gretel you know the story right
this guy gets married he's got a couple
of kids
his new wife doesn't relight the kids
you have a hundred times higher chance
by the way of being abused by a
stepparent than a biological parent just
so you know
so the stepmother doesn't like the kid
she tells the guy well why do you just
go put those kids out in the woods sold
oh they go out woods so they're lost
kids right they have nowhere to go so
they're wandering around out there in
the forest what happens they come across
a gingerbread house you think wow man
you're a starving kid gingerbread house
that's good news right not only is it a
house but it's made out of candy how
could anything possibly be any better so
when they go well and then there's this
grandmother date right there and you
know she starts to fatten them up she
puts I think it's Hansel in the cage and
she gets Gretel after a while to
basically work as their scullery maid
and it quick becomes quite obvious to
the children that she's actually
fattening them up so that she can put
them in the oven and eat them and so I
think what hanson does is I think Gretel
gives him this like bone from some
animal and the old witch is half blind
and every time she reaches into sort of
feel his leg he gives her the bone and
so like she's just not all that interest
in eating him in any ways the kids end
up pushing her in the oven and closing
it and getting the hell out of there so
you know it's a happy ending as far as
fairy tale school but it's an eatable
story right it's a classic story about
an eatable family be bloody wary of
people who do too much for you right
it's like if you have a mother or any
other relative for that matter
who's fattening you up on mercy and
candy the probability that her basic
goal is to eat you enough so that you
never leave the probability is
extraordinarily high and that's no joke
you know one of the things that you do
learn if you read about the sorts of
people who burst out of their mother's
basement because shoot up Dawson
colleges that often that's exactly the
situation they've been in right they're
burning with resentment in their
uselessness down in the basement for
five or six years you know they don't
have to leave they don't have to become
independent everything's done for them
so they never have to do anything for
themselves it's like it's not pretty
and so one of the rules for dealing with
people and I know this is actually a
rule for dealing with elderly people in
you know in homes for retired people is
do not do anything for anyone they can
do for themselves you're stealing from
that when you do that and it's a great
rule of thumb for kids like once they
can dress themselves they dress
themselves if they can set the table
even if it takes 20 minutes it's like
they're set in the table you're not
doing them a favor by helping them do
anything they can do themselves and this
gets caught it's kind of harsh you know
but it beats the hell out of the witch
and Hansel and Gretel so so anyways you
know one of the things we're going to
look at as well as the dark side of
positive motivations so now how are we
going to do this hmm one of the things
you might ask yourself is how in the
world do you know if something is true
now the first thing I would suggest is
that the attitude you guys should bring
to this class is that nothing that I
tell you is true okay now I don't mean
that you should be arrogantly skeptical
because that's not appropriate but you
should bring every critical faculty you
have to bear on what I tell you to see
if you can chip away at it because what
you want to do you want to build
yourself a body of knowledge that you
cannot undermine and the way you do that
is by trying to undermine it by hacking
away at the foundation of everything
you've got and if if the ideas can
withstand a tone long slot
then you've got something you got a
foundation you've got something you
could stand on that's going to be there
when things get rough and so I'm going
to tell you what I've found it's been
useful to me when things got rough but I
don't expect you to assume that that's
going to work for you and I don't want
you to to like I want you to listen and
to think but I want you to you know keep
your wits about you
now I'm going to tell you how I go about
trying to determine whether or not
something is true now first of all
there's different definitions of truth
and so we're going to basically flip
back and forth between to one definition
of truth is an objective definition and
we don't have to talk much about that
because you guys already know what that
is but there's another definition of
truth that that I think the best way of
defining it is as pragmatically true and
pragmatism is a branch of American
philosophy and it's a very sophisticated
branch of philosophy in fact I actually
think it's the most sophisticated brand
of philosophy part part probably because
it makes the least claims and what the
pragmatists state basically is well you
don't really know anything right you
don't have ultimate knowledge about
anything so your knowledge always bought
themselves in ignorance and so then the
question is well how do you know then if
anything is true and the pragmatists
would say well in a sense you don't what
you know always is if something is true
enough for a particular function so for
example your theory about getting to the
door might be that you can stand up and
walk there and you might well god only
knows what might happen on the way there
you know maybe there'll be an earthquake
or a ceiling tile fall on you or who
knows maybe of a heart attack you know
so you don't know whether you can get
there you can infer from past experience
but if you get there then what you can
say is my statement about truth was
sufficient so that the outcome was what
the theory predicted and so in some
sense what the pragmatists are saying is
every time you make a statement
especially if it's related to action
that you offer a theory of truth along
with that statement implicitly which is
that this is true enough if what I
predict happen happens
and so it's really it's a but very nice
theory because it doesn't require you to
be on missing about anything for things
to be true enough and you are in your if
you don't know everything about anything
and so obviously you're working in the
world with partial knowledge and it
works not all the time you get old you
get sick you die like I mean you're
you're not gonna work it out thoroughly
but so we're going to use that pragmatic
truth framework and we're going to use a
objective truth framework and one of the
propositions that I'm going to make to
you is that the the stories that are
associated with our deepest moral
intuitions are pragmatic truths and that
you need pragmatic truths and you need
objective truths and you need pragmatic
truths because you don't just need to
know what the world is made of you need
to know what to do about the fact that
the world's made out of things and
because you know human beings are
motoric creatures we act in the world we
act on the world and so what we need to
know is how is it that you should act on
the world and that is not a question
that can be addressed by objective
methods technically right because it's
actually a value question what should
you do science by its very methodology
refuses to answer such questions and you
know people confuse the fact that
science is value free sort of with the
idea that existence is value free it's
like that's that's that's a
philosophically primitive I would say
because science was actually set up to
get rid of the value of the subjective
value and it's in its technique so you
can't say well we set this thing up to
get rid of the value and look all the
values gone it's like there's no value
it's no no no no you put that domain out
of the range of consideration that
doesn't mean it doesn't exist it's just
it's just a different it requires
different it requires a different
philosophy a different outlook different
techniques different tools different
methods of proof all of these things and
so part of what we're going to do I'm
going to use objective truth as much as
I
Kanon because i think that that a lot of
what psychology as a science has being
able to offer in the last hundred years
is actually extraordinary useful for
elucidating some of the issues that
we're going to discuss because we really
have made some progress in understanding
the psyche as you know especially at a I
would say at a biological / behavioral
level we've got some pretty solid
information it's not perfect but it's
helpful okay so we're going to draw out
a bunch of sources we're drawing stories
we're going to draw on literature in a
drawing philosophy we're going to draw
on religion we're going to draw
mythology we're going to draw on biology
and psychology and there's this idea but
you should have learned about if you're
a psychologist called multi method multi
trait matrix so and this was invented by
a guy back in the 1950s I think it was
meal and cron back his famous paper that
was published in the 50s everyone is
supposed to know it no one ever pays any
attention to it but what they were
interested in was how do you know if
when you say that something exists like
let's say anger does anger exist
well the answer seems self-evident yes
well it's tricky you know because
generally no one comes up to you and
says anger you know they tell you a
little story where they use words
related to anger in the story and then
you sort of derive what they mean by
angry from the context and the context
is important in defining the reality
right so you don't know if that that the
central idea anger can be pulled out of
the context and then you can say well
that's a thing like like iron is a thing
or like mercury is a thing you know
because maybe it's not maybe it's a
pattern or maybe it's something that's a
convention or you know there may be all
sorts of things that are there
associated with it so one of cron back
and meals fundamental claims was that in
order to determine whether or not
something existed you had to be able to
detect it using different methods
now it's tricky because it's not obvious
what constitutes a different method
right
so you kind of
have to make a judgement but I would say
you use a multi method multi trait means
of determining what's true with your
senses how many do you have six because
you have proprioception right why why
why well let's say five for the sake of
simplicity why why don't one to increase
the likelihood of it being true you can
see something but not be able touch it
that might be a mirage maybe or right
yeah so you write multiple reasons for
it to be pointing to the fact to the
probability of it yes well that's
exactly it and then you you want it to
be so the sense idea is a really good
one because you can see that senses use
different modalities right it's like
obviously the eyes rely on
electromagnetic radiation and the ears
rely on vibrations in the air and touch
is really an atomic phenomena in some
sense you know because you're feeling
the outer surfaces of electrons with
your electron surfaces and um there's
taste which is again a molecular level
phenomena and smell and you know so our
idea kinda is if if all five of those
things detect it it's sufficiently real
so that we can use it to guide our
action and we won't be wrong so it's
five dimensions you need a five
dimensional analysis and that's evolved
so you might say well you know that's
let's call that a good estimate you need
five ways of detecting something before
you can be sure it's true now you know
when you're learning about Experimental
Psychology they tell you P is less than
0.05 right you use a measurement and
then you determine whether the
probability that that has manifested
itself exceeds a certain level of chance
and if it does then the thing exists but
that's that's actually not right it's
it's not right for experimental
psychology and experimental
psychologists have known it since the
late 50s you have to demonstrate that
the damn thing exists multiple different
ways
now what constitutes a different way can
be subject to debate it's a complicated
thing to sort out but you can kind of
figure it out great you know maybe you
use a physiological measurement and
self-report or something like
or use self-report and other reporter
you know and maybe you don't need five
but you probably need three or something
like that you know depending on them so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
tell you a story roughly speaking and I
want to make the story evident at five
or six different levels of analysis and
I want to show you how the story is the
same at all these levels of analysis now
the one one of the potential flaws of
that method is this so a Joseph Campbell
for example he wrote about hero
mythology right some of you probably
read the hero with a thousand faces and
one of the criticisms of Joseph Campbell
and people like him is that they read
the stories of multiple cultures but
they have an a priori framework and
because of the I priori framework they
only see what their theory tells them
that they're going to see they don't
look for the exceptions so it's a
problem with pattern recognition right
you may be able to recognize patterns
where they don't exist now my method
could could be criticized on that
grounds I think but the way I've tried
to protect myself against that was to
make sure that I drew from his enough
diverse sources so that the probability
that I would be able to tell a coherent
story across all those different types
of methods is vanishingly small now
you're going to have to decide if you
think that's true so um and I get I can
tell you roughly the dimensions of
analysis the idea is that I'm going to
talk to you about I put into practice
personally they work for me they work
for the people that I've taught them to
so those are family members often but
not only family members lots of other
people because I'm also a clinician
right and so it seems to work quite
nicely I have a lot of people write to
me and tell me that the ideas have
worked you know and so so I've got multi
rater
reliability there and then I think it's
manifest biologically and I think it's
manifest culturally and I think it's
manifested in these very very old
stories and anthropologically and so
forth so you know
make up your own mind you can you can
see you know and I think the other or
the other thing and I don't really know
what to do what to make of this you know
sometimes you have an intuition of truth
right is like maybe you're describing a
problem to someone and they say well
this seems to be at the heart of it they
give you a formulation and kind of goes
click and you think yeah that's how all
those things hang together it's a it's a
pattern recognition mechanism it's
insight mechanism people generally have
the feeling that when something like
that happens that something of truth has
been revealed now a very common response
from the students I've had in these
courses is that I never tell anyone
anything they don't already know so and
I think the reason for that is I'm
hoping the reason is is that what I'm
outlining are archetypal structures you
know and I've drawn a lot of my work
from you who was very interested in
architectures and so what should happen
and I think it will happen is when I
tell you a story you'll think oh yeah
right that's what that means and I see
and here's all the things that it
explains and so you'll have this sense
and that's the you talked about your
friend with the spiritual awakening
often one of the cognitive phenomena
that accompanies the spiritual awakening
is the connection of many many diverse
phenomena into a overarching unity and
you feel that like as a radical
simplification something like that a
decrease in entropy or something like
that it's a very very powerful sensation
so I mean there's other sources of what
you might call spiritual experience as
well but that's certainly one of them
and so you can see you know I'll tell
you these stories you can think oh well
you know how how does that story
manifest itself in your experience
that's a phenomenological level of truth
right so the phenomenologist s-- branch
of philosophy started by Heidegger not
exactly but let's say extended as well
as anyone extended it by Heidegger
Heidegger thought that Western
philosophy have gone wrong basically
since the time of Socrates which was you
know quite a long time and he said that
we were we became interested in what the
world was made of and how
we knew things and what we should have
been interested instead was the nature
and quality of being and what he meant
by being isn't the objective world what
he meant by being was the manner in
which you have experience and so there
are elements of being that aren't
objective elements and so I would say
pain is a phenomenological reality right
it's it's not something you can you can
index it objectively but the index is
not the phenomenon and you know is your
pain real see this is this is a question
for people who think there's no such
thing as meaning like you try to argue
yourself out of pain and see how far you
get you might think well that's not the
sort of meaning I meant it's like you
know a negative meaning is a place to
start right because if something is
negative and it's real it does imply
that there's something positive that's
real it might be harder to get a hold of
at least it's not pain you know so but
pain Descartes then I'll close with this
you guys can have a break Descartes
implemented a method he called radical
doubt when he went on his philosophical
journey and what Descartes looked for
was one thing he couldn't doubt because
he was probably clinically depressed and
he was just doubting everything it's
like well why how do I know the world
isn't just a mirage made by an evil
demon to you know to to obfuscate
reality from me while his conclusion was
the one thing that he could not dispute
was that he was and could think now I
don't think Descartes really meant what
we meant by think I think he meant more
what we would mean by experience because
thought has become a much more narrowly
defined I you know term since the time
of Descartes so I don't think he meant I
think therefore I am I think he meant
something like I experience I have
experienced therefore I am but
regardless of that modern people think
about it as thought Heidegger was
different Heidegger basically said the
one thing you can't dispute is that that
experience is your experience it exists
you
can't it'sit's almost by definition
right it's like the definition of exist
and then he was interested in what the
fundamental elements of existence of
existence were and they're not atoms
like you know like the fundamental
elements of the object of world there
are more things like pain and for me
that was the thing that stopped me from
doubted it's like I cannot doubt the
existence of pain it seems real and I
might say it seems more real than
anything else
now you might say you don't believe that
but I would say I don't care what you
think you believe I'll watch you when
you're in pain and every single one of
your actions will indicate that you
believe in it and not only that that you
can't not believe in it
right it's there and it's there so much
that well that's a meaning and so that
it's in that way that Heidegger at least
in part thought of existence as or
experience as composed of meanings and
so part of the reason that this course
is called knots of meaning is because
one of the things we're going to look at
is the structure of meaning and we're
going to start with negative meaning
because from my perspective it's look
you can doubt whether or not good exists
but once I'm done telling you about the
things I know about human history there
won't be a single person in this room
who thinks that evil doesn't exist and
you might think that's a bloody horrible
thing to learn but it's not it's
unbelievably useful because once you can
establish something that you cannot deny
then you can move from that and I think
you can hypothesize that if you're
capable of detecting radical evil I'll
tell you about unit 731 at some point or
you can look them up yourself I wouldn't
recommend it by the way once you can
identify radical evil and you think well
that's that's just beyond a doubt that's
reprehensible there's no justification
for that whatsoever no matter what
whenever well then you've got something
to stand on and you can start thinking
well what's the absolute opposite of
that then you know it might be how is it
that you could conduct yourself so that
in your sphere of influence the
probability like that anything like that
would ever happen is reduced to the
absolute max
well that's a reasonable moral question
and and I don't think it's something
that you can dispense with with like a
casual nihilism
I don't think a nihilist can dispense
with it because he even nihilists suffer
thank God for that you know it's their
only uh
it's their only source of potential
salvation sometimes they notice it oh
I'm suffering about all this nihilism
maybe that indicates that there's
something flawed in it it's always
possible so okay so let's take a break
we'll take a break further oh come back
what time is it I want to make sure my
clock is BA mmm 2:58 okay come back at
3:50 we'll see you there and then I'll
talk to you more about the technical
elements of the class